on passe aux sports tour sochaux le
match a lieu demain à 14 heures au stade
de la vallée du cher pour le compte de
la 29e journée de ligue 2 tours 11e avec
36 points sochaux en position relégable
un véritable challenge pour le club
tourangeau en écoute le milieu de
terrain laurent apprécié ce championnat
de ligue 2 est très atypique avec des
blocs
très compact quand il se déplace à
l'extérieur demain c'est ce qu'on aura
aussi et en plus ils ont ils ont
énormément énormément de vitesse demande
donc ce show donc il faudra il faudra
aussi être être patient dans la
construction du jeu mais aussi est très
très compacte quand on le perd et très
désagréable sur le porteur du ballon